Okay, welcome everybody to another Zoom call, so we don't have a lot of questions today,
so if you have something, we better start typing, where it's going to be a very short
Zoom call.
Reminder to go to your home page, members site to look at any updates.
I did not put on here because it's not particularly a member.
There are issues, but there are a lot of updates on the autoimmune course, so if you've
been following that or you've gone through that, make sure you jump back on it and look
at some of the updated information on there, if you haven't.
Concrete, comorbidity of an autoimmune disease or a family member does, and that's the
following that.
Remember, you can make self-scheduled follow-up calls on our website, our member site, and
all over, and let's get to your questions.
Is nato, fermented soybeans, a food that is good to add to my diet?
I was diagnosed with estrogen driven breast cancer four years ago.
So normally, if it was just soybeans, if you were eating tofu, I would say no, but nato
is a traditional Japanese dish that is fermented soybeans.
You can make your own with soybeans.
You'd want to get organic soybeans, because most soybeans on the market are GMO soybeans,
which is another issue, but get organic soybeans and you put them in the oven, there's a procedure
to do it.
I was going to make them one time, but I didn't do it.
That is how you would make your own nato.
Nato fermented soybeans is used traditionally, like I said, in Japanese dishes, as a little
side dish, where they'll have large tablespoons of them that they'll have at every dinner.
Positive fermented soybeans, fermented soybeans have been shown to dislodge estrogens from
estrogen receptors.
So for using fermented soybeans, or in a food product, like nato, works differently than
using an aromatase inhibitor product, like dim.
So dim and other natural aromatase inhibitors help your body clear bad estrogens, so it helps
you get rid of bad estrogens, it decreases your total estrogen load, which is great for
people with an estrogen positive cancer, or even a PR positive, or her too positive cancer.
But you're not going to get rid of all your estrogens, and it will not dislodge bad estrogens
that have already attached to estrogen receptors on the cell membrane, because that's really
what the problem is with estrogen driven cancers, hormone driven cancers, attached to the
hormone receptors on the cell membranes, which are actually apoptotic receptors, so they block
apoptosis.
That's the problem with estrogens in estrogen driven cancer.
While even drug aromatase inhibitor will even do a better job of getting rid of all your
estrogens, that's why a lot of people don't like taking it, because you'll have no estrogens
left in your body, even the good estrogen, and it can make you feel not well.
It does not dislodge bad estrogens from the estrogen receptors, only the fermented soybeans
will do that.
So to answer your question is are fermented soybeans in the form of a food, like nato, a good
food source, or someone who has estrogen driven cancer, absolutely yes.
The negative is it's definitely an acquired taste, so if you've never tasted it, you might
not like it.
So it isn't acquired taste that you have to work up to, but if you like it, you should be
taken it, should be eaten every day, to be very good for you.
I get a burning sensation sometimes where I had radiation in the past after my left breast
mastectomy nearly four years ago.
One would be the cause of this and what could I do to prevent it.
So a burning sensation anywhere in your body can be a side of something going on, so that
can be cells reproducing to heal the area.
If it's where you had post surgery, where you had radiation, it's a concern.
Of course, it is because you can get cancer coming back at an area where you had cancer
before.
Certainly, you could get a totally different type of cancer where you had radiation.
That's what I don't like about soft tissue radiation.
There's plenty of data that shows in higher incidence of melanomas where there was radiation
for breast cancer or other cancers.
So yeah, it's a concern.
It's something that if you're still getting regular checkups with an oncologist, getting a
PET scan might be appropriate.
It can be just the tissue healing, can be just scar formation too, so I don't want to raise
too much concern when it's not necessary.
But it's something to be aware of.
Certainly, when you have scar formation from an injury in the past, you can get that type
of feeling, even if it's like, you cut yourself really bad, you had stitches done, you could
get a birdie or a tingle or a weird sensation where that was done, it's just scar formation.
So I don't want to raise too much concern, but you always want to suspect possibilities.
What can you do for it?
You wouldn't do, put anything other that would increase replication, but I would certainly
think some different herbal salves could be beneficial.
I think colledula salve would be a good idea for that.
I don't know that I would use company, I use colledula salve might be a good idea, even
just some coconut oil could be good to go over scar over where you had radiation could be
help, could be healing and prevent further scar formation.
Yes, is infrared light or red light therapy okay for bone metastasis, bone metastatic
bone cancer?
Not sure about both, or one of them I hear some can cause circulation, blood flow and
not necessarily good for tumors.
So I don't know that I would use near or far infrared over a bone cancer, it's really
hard because okay, so yes, if you look at the data for infrared light or red light therapy,
the data is that reason why it helps it heals and it increases circulation to the area.
For an overall physiological picture, that's how your body heals, you increase circulation,
brings oxygen, brings nutrients, it helps heal tissue.
Well, you don't want to necessarily increase circulation around the cancer in one sense of
the word and increase cancer's ability to metabolize, however, if you heat a cancer,
it is far less stable than healthy tissue.
So in that sense, using infrared therapy over a cancer can actually help your body kill
the cancer because your cells, your healthy cells are very stable to increase temperature
to a certain degree.
You're not going to have tissue breakdown until you get to maybe 106-107 degrees Fahrenheit,
whereas cancer cells can die in 102 degrees Fahrenheit.
So that's a side benefit of like that has been pushed personas, but I've always said really
the chance of you really raising your body temperature up to 102 degrees Fahrenheit while
you're in a sauna is probably pretty slim.
You could take your, you're an oral temperature before you go to the sauna and take it right
after you get out of the sauna and see if there's that much of a change in total body temperature
and most cancers are fairly deep, they're not on the skin.
So I don't know that that would be really a benefit of a sauna.
Now if you're using a true infrared light, there's a lot of infrared lights on the market
that, you know, it's a bulb, an infrared light bulb that you screw into any socket and you
could put that near your tissue and it's a red light and it's sold as an infrared light,
but in truth, there is literally no infrared coming out of there, infrared by definition
whether it be near or far or mixed infrared, it's not going to be visible.
So it's not in the visible light spectrum, so you won't see a light.
So we have our hyperthermia units, you don't see a light because it's a true, far infrared
heat source.
So it's heating deep and it goes through the tissue and it has to be a direct skin contact
and it will go down an inch or a little bit more, maybe an inch and a half, but it's not
going to go a whole lot deeper than that.
So it's still only beneficial to kill cancer that's fairly near the surface.
So if I have, you know, cancer that's metastasized to my pelvis, the chance that infrared light
is going to get deep enough to raise the core temperature to kill cancer cells is pretty
slim.
If I have had my breast right near the surface of my tissue, yeah, it certainly possibly
can, or if it's a bone that's right near the surface, let's say it's in the slightest
process of your lumbar spine, yeah, you could probably, for sure, get it added with
a true infrared source.
But again, we're talking about a true infrared source of light, not one of those bulbs you
could buy on the market, a true infrared source of light is going to be, they're expensive
little tools, they're about $5,000.
Red light therapy is just using different colors that affect the skin.
That doesn't go deep at all.
But it's going to use colors that will affect the skin and affect the tissues.
I don't see any problem with using just a red light therapy machine at all.
They can be very beneficial.
They're making physiological changes not directly, but from a reflex reaction in your body's physiology.
And then there's another type of light therapy called laser therapy.
So laser, there's actually four different classes of laser.
Most of the lasers on the market, let's say that a car proctor might have would be a level
two or level three, or maybe a level three B laser.
The level four lasers are the most powerful lasers.
Those are the lasers if you can put a fitted apparatus on it, it comes out as a pinpoint
beam that would actually cut tissue that's what you'd use for surgery.
But as a wide beam, it can be extremely healing.
So laser therapy, it can be very healing.
Now there is controversy whether you should use a three B or a level four laser with cancer
because if it's healing, could it actually increase the metabolic rate and heal and keep
a cancer alive?
So all the laser companies have a caveat that you're not supposed to use over a cancer or a
tumor or a cyst.
However, I know as several years ago there was some research coming out of Europe that
was actually showing using laser on a tumor was helping your body heal it and kill the tumor.
Now I've always been afraid to use laser right over a person's breast tumor or over a person's
prostate tumor just because there's just not any data on it.
So if a person was in dire straits and your cancer was going the wrong way, could they do
laser?
If it was me, I would.
We personally own a class four laser.
Class four lasers are super expensive, they're like 45 grand, but there's, you know, I bought
it because I'm addicted to things like that.
But it's unbelievable for healing, joint issues, disk issues, sprains, strains, muscle issues,
injuries to ligaments, tendons.
There's not a lot, I mean, physical therapies, clinics do not use lasers and the only reason
is because insurance doesn't pay for them.
I have a friend who owns, who's a part owner of 11 physical therapy clinics, they do not
use laser in their clinics because they don't get any insurance reimbursement and physical
therapy clinics, by the way, are 100% financially driven by insurance reimbursement, they don't
get, they don't get self paid patients.
So they charge, you know, for $500 a visit, it's all charged to insurance.
So there's a therapy that doesn't get covered by insurance, they don't do it.
That's the only reason why they don't do it.
So you have to find a clinic that has a, if you use a level two laser, it's really not
to do anything.
Maybe a level three B or a level four laser, that's the only good laser on the market.
So it's something you could certainly try, the danger is that would it cause the tumor
to grow, there's just no data, nobody's ever done it.
I know the studies that there was a couple of studies that were published in Spain, I believe,
but that was a while ago.
That was even eight, 10 years ago, they were very positive.
They were using them for cancers over there, but understand that's what Europe was much
more open, alternative things.
Medical fields in Europe have shut down, just as bad as the FDA had shut down things here
there.
Pharmaceutical companies have basically taken over pretty much the world and all the countries
medical, you know, like the FDA's of every combed country.
So that kind of research is just not going to come out anymore.
So if I was in a situation where my cancer was growing crazily and I've tried everything
else, I would certainly do the laser over it, it's like it's worth a shot.
If I was doing pretty well, and you know, I'm just thinking of another therapy to add,
I don't know that I would necessarily do it, I would not be afraid of infrared light or
red light therapy over bolin metastasis, but obviously with anything you just go slow and
you make sure you're, you know, going to change too strong of a change in science and
symptoms.
And that's really questions we had, so there's going to be a short meeting if you guys don't
have a lot more questions.
Have you heard of Invita Medical Center in Arizona doing a procedure called CIPI chemo immune
precision injections?
No, I'm not familiar with that.
I am familiar with Invita.
We've had three or four people that have gone there, but they went there for insulin-potentiated
chemotherapy.
You know, there's more places that are doing insulin-potentiated chemotherapy, but for
a while they were the only clinic around that was doing it.
And the people that had gone there were happy with them, they, I don't remember anybody
being unhappy there.
So yeah, they have some new procedure, they legally, Arizona's the most open state for alternative
practitioners doing different things.
So Arizona law has allowed a lot of things where you can't just do that most places.
So yeah, that sounds very interesting, I have to look up that I would look at their clinic
for a number of, probably since last summer.
So inject chemo in target area not the whole body for medesthetic lesions, that's quite
interesting.
Yeah, and again, you're probably not going to find any published studies on that.
They can have maybe some of their own data in Arizona that they can self-publish and put
out to the people, but again, like anything, some cancers just don't respond to a chemo
and some cancers do.
So everybody's going to be different with their success right with that too.
But it's not necessarily the type of cancer, it's how that cancer is growing in that person's
body.
Just like two people with not-hodge-consolent phoma can get the same chemo and one responds
well and one doesn't respond well at all, not that they got injured by the chemo even.
It didn't stop the cancer, well they have the same cell type, why wouldn't it stop the
cancer?
Because everybody's personal chemistry is different.
So that's just the way it is, it's the same way with supplements, one might work perfectly
with some.
One person doesn't work well with another person, so they're going to have the same issue.
So that's the same issue with a lot of people will say, well, should I do insulin-potentiated
chemotherapy?
Well, insulin-potentiated chemotherapy is still chemotherapy, they're just giving you a lower
dose, but they have to give you more times.
They're going in weekly, typically for that, so it can have similar ill effects on your
body over time, because you're getting many more doses.
But for someone who is so hypersensitive to any types of drugs, many times because cytochrome
P450 pathways in their body and their liver is impaired, they're just hypersensitive drugs
to eat insulin-potentiated chemotherapy is better.
But then the caveat to that is that, well, if that chemotherapy, whether it's low dose
using insulin prior, or it's a high dose, going to your oncologist, if that chemotherapy
doesn't work for my cancer, the low dose isn't going to work for my cancer either.
So you just really don't know until you administer it, so what supplements do you recommend to
get rid of glyphosate in your body?
There was a product out there that worked marketing, I believe, but I don't remember the name
of it.
So there isn't anything specific that will get rid of glyphosate or mercury toxicity or
lead poisoning or mycotoxins.
It is you're having to use key-lation products and you're using products to get rid of this
stuff that's already in the cell that will uptick the production of glutathione.
So remember, glutathione is made into a cellular antioxidant and glutathione is made in the mitochondria
of your cells and glutathione will help get rid of toxins out of the cell, but then
using key-laters will help grab onto them and bring them through the blood out of the
tissues and into your liver.
So that's really what you're looking for now.
We've talked many times about the pros and cons of using something that will increase glutathione
with a cancer patient, because many of the cancer therapies, especially from a medical
standpoint, are therapies that are stimulating reactive oxygen and species.
So you're using glutathione, you have the possibility of keeping a cancer alive because cancer
cells are much more susceptible to end death by reactive oxygen and species than a healthy
cell is.
So I would stick to the key-later type things and so Chris, you're already taking, I think
have I remember correctly, you're already taking a bunch of stuff from cell core.
A lot of the cell core products are exactly what we're talking about.
So cell core products, they have the human effulvic acid, they have, depending on what product
it is, it might have charcoal, it may have different types of key-laters.
Now there are some other, just your general type of key-laters, which are EDTA and DMSA.
Those are general key-laters that have been shown statistically and research-wise to work
great for heavy metals and such.
And then there's the ones in cell core that are just more general key-laters and binders.
Another type of photoimmune therapy, infrared light, also injects to the site of the tumor.
Yeah, that's a type of what's called photo biomodulation.
So a photo biomodulation is using laser slash infrared slash a light therapy of some kind.
You're even getting photo biomodulation when you're doing rife.
But photo biomodulation really got its name from using not infrared but using laser.
And then using a chemical.
Or you could do photo biomodulation with any chemical.
Any chemical that's going to be attracted to kills and cancer directly.
There's a lot of natural things that do that.
One photo biomodulator thing you could do at home is using methylene blue.
And I before you go to bed with your rife machine, you could use methylene blue.
With an infrared sauna or using it with red light therapy.
I did put a video on methylene blue on the member site on the homepage of the member site.
If you want to watch that, that can be an agent as well.
But I know photo biomodulation is done at some clinics as well.
Yeah, photo biomodulation type therapies do not injure healthy cells at all.
The argument is how much it's doing to the cancer cell is debatable so.
And again, you get some rogue university that wants to get funded
because you got some naturally alternative believing scientists that they may get one source
of funding to get something published.
Then it gets thrown under the rug and trampled on by standards of care.
And so unfortunately, even most of the large colleges that are doing cancer research
are only getting funding to do studies that have to do with pharmaceuticals.
I used to have a staff person that worked with me and her husband was a brilliant scientist.
He was a cancer researcher at the University of Minnesota for decades.
He totally 100% believed in what we do.
Matter of fact, he said, he said, Kevin, I asked my boss once,
how come we're not working harder to fight a cure for cancer?
Because he was a cancer researcher and he says, we're not trying to fight a cure for cancer.
We're just here to get our next grant.
Well, unfortunately, he was very honest and that's a very sad truth of where we're at in this country.
Is that, you know, everybody's just looking to get their next grant.
They don't really care about outcomes.
All right, Mark, I saw your comment.
Thank you.
We'll talk sweet, baby.
All right.
Well, we will call it a night.
Good meeting today.
Thanks for everybody being on and we'll see you guys all next week.
Bye-bye.